good morning Millennials welcome back to
the CH and happy Friday it's a c it's an
extravagan it's the end of the week oh
my goodness oh my goodness hey Jax how
you turn I'm turn good a heart earned
end of the week it's been a sick week
for your girl I've seen you guys
complaining in the comments and I just
want to say imagine how I feel you're
tired tired she you're tired of me
sniffling imagine how I feel sniffling
have some compassion how you feeling are
you wearing my shirt I'm wearing this
outfit that you gave me when I was
pregnant because I have so much cabbage
in you're cabbag in this very moment
cing in this moment and Zach bought me a
fresh cabbage yesterday that is the the
biggest cabbage at the patch so the
leaves are huge and they literally go up
to my neck if I just open one button
look cabbage oh my God and you thought
you thought that the gorgeous Norma
kamale set that I gave you should smell
like cabbage that's how you receive the
gifts that I give I wanted to look
amazing today and I said oh some of my
most amazing outfits were gifted to me
by Claudia not the black of my
cardigan Dark Times dark times no and I
needed something where you wouldn't see
all this cabbage but I didn't want to do
like another sweatshirt oh you know what
it was chy actually I had already put my
hair up and I had already put my eyebrow
glue on so I couldn't put something over
my head so I went for my button downs
and then I saw this outfit that I love
so much and yes it is a little oversized
I'm like teeny
tiny and I thought
perfect okay noted I love this outfit L
tur Deo me too that outfit's kind of
like it really is a Sisterhood of the
Traveling Pants type of outfit it looks
good on everyone whether it's a little
small on you whether it's a little big
on you like it could be snug but it
could also be oversized like it's kind
of the most amazing outfit and I think
like each sister should wear it it would
fit every sister like that's what's
magical about it did every sister the
last time I wore it was at your birthday
and I was 9 months pregnant slay the
house down boots boots y boots today 5
and a half months out slaying the house
down boots cabbage slaying the house
down boots cabbage write it down for
title that's just one of many options we
will have today even though like let's
let's give some inside baseball tea to
like the girles listening today I'm very
particular about titles because it's
like so slay the house down boots
cabbage is like a funny thing that we've
said but if you are toast agnostic and
you're scrolling through the Hearts it's
not something that's going to make you
want to listen not only that it's too
long like I have a character limit on
the title doesn't work for me I show up
on our YouTube cover photo the way it
shows up on our social carts even the
way it shows up in the charts if it's
this long sentence people can't read the
whole sentence I love a short quick
nasty title like especially one that
like when Taylor Swift does something
it's like so great for our business like
Taylor on the field earlier in this week
that's our highest listen to episode not
necessarily because of the title cuz I
think a lot of people wanted to know
what we were going to say about t they
know for sure that we're going to be
talking about it and then actually maybe
some people who are casually scrolling
the charts they see this episode that's
like in the top 1% and they're like oh
the top 1% talking about Taylor on the
field let me listen that actually would
get new listeners no they see oh the
1centers are talking about Taylor Swift
right and how many other podcasts in
like the top 20 overall podcast episodes
of the day have tailor in the title that
day like really none it's all about you
know war in the election also once again
another Friday has rolled around I have
an overwhelming amount of options for
weenie of the week and I might have one
Queenie I was thinking about it as I was
doing my makeup this morning and then I
forgot about it but it will come to me I
had I had some early starters but it's
just like it's
hard it's hard to like get so in the
weeds you know cuz then like I'm like is
this person deserving of weenie and then
I zoom out and I'm like senoir sinir is
my weenie yeah no you're you need to
like kind of reset your level I have my
weenie oh the weenie has spoken I can't
wait the weenie has emerged oh the
weenie has made him or her or themselves
known oh my God Is it okay you know what
I guess I'll just have to wait and see
they've made they themselves known they
it's a group of people or a non-binary
person you'll have to stay tuned till
the end of the show to find out
yikes um so we of course have a great
show for you guys today I was inspired
by my absolutely gorgeous Drop Dead Diva
[__] of a sister to get a spray tan
today which I'm going to do later today
just to kind of like look gorgeous for
the weekend love that for you you've
just inspired me to book my next spray
tan you know one thing about 2024 like
let's stay on top of our Beauty
treatment so we stop looking like rats
like we're on camera every day and like
the fact that for years I wasn't
consistently getting spray tans
consistently getting lash lips
consistently taking care of myself
consistently exfoliating like we are
going to be beautiful this year that's
the goal [__] I love that for us and
like I've said once I'm done weaning
it's over for you [__] so you better
enjoy these last few weeks you better
enjoy them by the way all you [__]
who've been like laying dormant while
Jackie's kind of been like in her
nesting hibernating you know big
breasted cabbage years like watch the
[__] out [__] wake up wake up she's
coming for you enjoy these last few
weeks your time is winding down oh yeah
just wait till she starts shooting
herself up with OIC it's really over for
you [__] yeah I mean I said you're
not going to do that I I've decided
that's just not in the cards for me
right now um I'll let you guys know if
if that changes for any reason but I I
really don't know why it would listen
your decision is your decision and and
it pains me to make that decision cuz
I'm so eager like to see to see what
it's like like to experience the juice
and the Magic by the way the cool thing
about it is that like it lasts one week
so like I could shoot you up I could do
it like one week and just I could shoot
like by the way then this I'm not
recommending this I'm not a doctor I'm
just saying like you I could bring some
and like Sho you up just see how I feel
I just know I'm going to be addicted no
I know by the way it's literally heroin
in a needle it's like my version of
heroin no it's my version of heroin too
I don't think I would like traditional
heroin I think every everybody likes
heroin is that everyone does that was a
crazy part of Mike Santino's book that I
can't stop talking about it because it
was so good at the very height of his
addiction he had gotten sober like many
times but really fake sober just so we
could get back to work at the very
height of his addiction he had like
literally spent every he was making
millions he had not a dollar to his name
he had sold all of his cars everything
to buy drugs and his girlfriend and his
parents like knew he was a drug addict
so they were keeping an eye on him his
friend came picked him up he ran in the
car they drove to Newark and this guy
his friend was like I know where we can
score some cheap drugs they pick it up
they go to the guy's house Mike opens
like the tinf foil thing and he's like
oh my God it's heroin and he had never
done heroin before and he like said he
was not going to do it and I forget what
actually happened I think he did it or
like Lauren his now wife called him at
the second he was about like thinking
about doing it it was like this crazy
Moment In the book and yeah he was like
he was like I was a crazy addict but my
line was heroin like I was never going
to do heroin but then here he was faced
with the only option of heroin
yeah damn and I can't talk about her
without talking about that episode of
you okay yeah it's just I feel like that
coughs proves to people that I'm sick
like you just to cut it out the time
ises and it's a I don't have a chronic
cough right now it was just a clearing
of the throat because I'm on the men and
I'm hoping that by Monday I will have
watched the Barbie movie and I'll be
able to discuss it without sounding nily
so as I was saying I really can't talk
about the drug heroin without thinking
about that episode well that's segment
Dr Phil did on those three sisters who
were addicted to heroin and who lived in
that sort of like cracked in and how I
spoke about it on the toast no actually
I think it was the breath like many many
years ago and it turned out one of them
was a bre and she like dmed me and she
said she thought it was hilarious I'm
like oh okay classic the toast is my
heroin they had Tapped Out the veins in
their arms and they started shooting up
between their to CLA stop Claudia just
stop it no honestly like I feel like no
we're moving we're frea frea we're
Switching gears okay here here's what
something that said that happened to me
this morning I saw on Instagram this
like absolutely gorgeous picture of
Ariel Charis on her Instagram story is
just looking so sick and I was like What
if I just swiped up and I really wanted
this coach she had like the cutest
outfit on it's it's very I think it's
from yesterday cuz it was very early in
her stories it's a white coat okay she
has like a Chanel bag a white coat
leggings like it's just like a cool girl
like Upper East Side mom and I'm like I
think I need to look like that let me it
okay so why didn't you just hit the copy
paste $1,500 jacket like girl come on
Orel Charis let me see what it's made of
your mom she did do a look for less and
I love I see how how sicking okay I see
the coat where's the swipe up oh she's
th posted all these throwback
oh no by the way you're you're too far
gone it's prior it's over okay so let me
go back to the Cod and analyze it tap
the link tap the link it's right there
it's not linked oh it must have expired
it was from
yesterday $1,500 and then my queen she
was like oh let me do a look for Le I
see I see it on the grid so now she said
oh here I'll link a jacket for less for
you broke [__] I'm like okay great
I'll do the only her dupe is from
revolve I'm like that's not the dupe
that's the goal you know yeah but what
about that one for you that's really
like where you're where you like to shop
I don't know compared to like the one
that she posted I just felt like it
would be cheap like even though it was a
$300 coat like it definitely wasn't
cheap but like I don't know it didn't
feel right I wanted the one well the
thing is I do really like the style of
coat so I do want
to persuade you to get it all right calm
down I'm not getting it and I just feel
like you need it I feel like I need it
too even though I don't really otherwise
how would you be warm if you didn't have
this coat well I do have my vest that
I'm currently wearing that was $4 from
Amazon so I feel good about that I also
am wearing my 1989 tailor merch that I
ordered in October that took four months
to come that arrived literally yesterday
so you're feeling warm enough I'm
feeling warm enough and I just want to
thank Taylor because honestly like her
having a four-month lead time like makes
me feel so good about our toast merch
which if you've ordered like you should
be getting in like literally a week or
two which is in a Frac of the tailor
time right so thanks Taylor we love you
for that yeah I just think you should
get that coat I really like it I think
it would just elevate it would it
wouldn't just be about the cat it would
kind of change who you are as a person
sorry okay I you would wear with
everything day or night and everyone say
oh my God there's Claudia just like kind
of their breath would be taken away by
you in in that coat Oh no you're like
kind of convincing me also I can change
a person wait what if you get the coat
for
me no what if we find a reason why you
should treat yourself no okay I need to
find like an I know no no I could that's
easy I need a coupon code I should have
done honey like I should have but like
the brand was wardrobe like they don't
do coupon codes you know like they're
not like us no you just have to what if
Ariel Charis is just like done with the
cat and she could give it to me even
though she's probably like a size double
zero just get the
coat I don't know $1,500 is a lot of
money on a Cod no but why don't you
order the code if it does if you put it
on it doesn't change who you are then
return it and if it does then you're
meant to have it and you'll wear it so
many times it'll justify the price coats
are expensive like when they're made of
things that will keep you warm when
they're made of coat when they're made
of real coat that's like a real
coat like one thing about me like I for
no reason like will defend Ariel Charis
to the death like she's just a person I
follow on the internet who I feel
fiercely protective over there's a few
people like that like I'm always going
to B for them even though I literally
don't even know them and would they do
the same for you no actually I don't
know Ariel charis's character but I
imagine she would and it's not tip for
Tat you don't do it to get it in return
you do it because it's the right thing
to do like Britney momes won't be
defending me anytime soon but I'll keep
defending her no no exactly like I do it
because my job is to comment on the
culture and I'm going to speak from the
heart yeah yeah and you're not going to
like add to their burden to their pile
they have enough people coming at them
no it's so true and just having been
someone who has been piled on on the
internet a couple of times like I know
what that's like and I'm literally like
never going to be a part of it you know
except if it's Justin
Timberlake oh I'm I'm sorry this
conversation is really only talking
about girls like I feel differently
about girls and boys like boys can
handle it for real yeah also celebrities
versus influences is different as we
stated so many times by the way Justin
Timberlake and Ariel Charis I couldn't
be more
different
yeah I'm glad that we've established
that cuz I think people were confused I
did however buy the socks from her ltk
swipe up so you got a piece of the magic
I got a piece of the magic and I spent
$30 on socks like she's insane
I'm sure your feet will be so warm we
live for it I love enabling people to
buy nice things it's really one of my
passions in life and I've also recently
like my itch has been
reactivated yeah like you're feeling
like you want to invest in some things
feeling like shopping feeling like
shopping till I'm dropping cuz I'm
coming out
ofation we go shopping together when I
come down yes and I drive you and I got
like one thing recently I'll drive and
it just no I'll drive oh you know what I
realized I was playing around with my
Tesla
yesterday I realized you know how you
don't like Tesla because it's like a
golf cart in terms of stopping and
starting it's not traditional the way we
were all taught to drive which is foot
on the brake at all times you can change
the settings so that it will drive like
a car that you're used to so if you ever
want to drive it you could drive it that
way oh we should definitely do that and
you should probably do that too just so
you can you're like a new driver you
should know how to drive one type of car
no I drove dak's car the other day it
wasn't pretty but we made it home yeah I
just just honestly like whenever you
talk about driving like I get the vibe
like you don't want to succeed like for
real what is it scared I do want to see
I want more than anything for this not
to be like this big impediment in my
life but I just I'm too cautious of a
person you know and I can't just throw
caution to the wind on this it's too
important no I know that so like it
would be more cautious of you to set up
your Tesla like all the other cars on
the planet why I only need to really
know how to master my own car and I find
it easier to drive this way like I'm
more comfortable I don't want to keep my
foot on the brake at all
times okay I could just like sit out of
light and my both feet are willy-nilly
how crazy what are you going to do a
dance never know jig you never know how
are the stories today I feel better than
yesterday oh okay and I didn't even
think yesterday was so bad yeah they
came together in a nice manner any
follow-up stories on T's arm Tike I
would love no
T what else do you want to know has
Christina spoken out like anything oh I
don't know if I would click if Christina
spoke out like I don't think I would
notice that it wouldn't pop off the page
to me CU she's always like in People
magazine like sharing her favorite
bracelet you
know yeah I know like she's always in
People magazine sharing her favorite
bracelet so I don't know if I would
notice I kind of like scroll past the
headlines about and by the way what's so
funny there was there was a story line
in selling Sunset like season one or two
that Christine Quinn said like Heather
was so upset that Christine Quinn said
how um Heather is always in People
magazine like sharing her favorite
muffin recipe tar Musa married the same
woman yeah twice yeah yeah he
did yeah so I really like Heather and
Tark though so I'm not going to say
anything you're not gonna be a hater no
I really like Heather and if a equals b
and b equals c and she loves tar and I
love Heather then I love tar I love
using the theorem of logic a equal b b
equal C know what is that the
chain what's that theory Theory chain
Theory like a equals b and b equals c
then a equals c it's never not right no
it's so factual and don't even start
like when we throw D in there and then a
equals D no that's too much it's hair
too far also let me tell you about a new
thing I'm experiencing that's actually
ruining my life um I woke up at 3:00 in
the morning and I went back to bed at
6:00 and like I just woke up like an
animal like at my usual time which is
about 8 8:30 I actually didn't get out
of bed till 9:00 I I really couldn't I
don't know what the [__] is up with that
and it's really pissing me off and it
has to it has to be done it has to be
stopped well at least when you come here
you can make yourself useful at those
hours oh my God give a little bottle but
I would love that but like no you know
no I think you would like it and then
Ben wakes up and he's like are you awake
and I'm like yeah cuz I was I scrolled
on my phone I was literally laying there
for like 30 minutes I'm like I have to
do something I'm so bored and so Ben was
like are you on your phone I'm like yeah
he's like well that's why you he starts
yelling at me he's like that's why you
can't sleep I'm like do you think I want
to be here like do you think I want to
be doing this right now okay not to be
the Ben's Advocate but it's true like
you turning on your phone tells your
brain hey it's awake time you'd be
better off just turning on your Kindle
please wow yeah the light from your
phone signals to your brain that it's
time to be awake so you're actually
accomplishing like the exact opposite
thing of what you're setting out to do
oh so we have gotten to a place in this
show where you took my husband's side
noted yeah it's dark times noted and I
will be calling your husband later I
think actually that Ben took my side
because that would have been my
argument tell Zach he will be hearing
from my people you're going to take his
side I'm going to set up a call with
Zach ask him what's going on in your
marriage and how I can help make it
worse
what would he want you to take his side
about I feel like you guys disagree on
like the dumbest most random stuff like
yeah like I can't even I can't even
remember and whenever I'm at your house
you know I ride for you yeah now it's
usually cuz you're right but I still
like even if you weren't right I
wouldn't feel right about not taking
your side maybe I would just like walk
away and we love when we're like having
a disagreement to like opening it up to
the jury which is really the worst thing
you can do for a marriage or just any
sort of relationship yet you know
nevertheless we persist and I always
ride for you so the fact that not only
you would take my husband's side but you
do it publicly on this show here noted
that's how much I care about tury sleep
I'm not going to tell you what you want
to
hear
noted I think after this I'm going to
listen to Good
Guys
noted and I'm going to like And
subscribe you know what I think I'm
going to do I think I'm gonna go listen
to Reese's book club podcast and like
And subscribe and maybe share it on my
Instagram to my millions of devoted
follow followers maybe that's what I'll
do whoa she got me there yeah maybe I'll
start my
own wow hit me where it hurts yeah but
and you would do that to the redheads
like it's not just about me we a
collective yeah no and I would I would
actually just it would be a spite
podcast but then curb comes back on
Sunday exciting that is very exciting
they did like a big premiere for it
Larry was on the Today's Show Larry's
looking good I didn't see it oh why do I
get the vibe you like hate Larry like
what is no I don't you're just like
giving like I hate Larry energy what
wrong I am I am but I love curb no it's
the best show on TV and actually so I
just feel like he's a little no offense
Demi levado being like this is the last
season of curb oh stop it we should by
the way thank God for that no I'm glad
for it but like stop saying that I think
this is like the final season of curb
until he comes back yeah no they say he
always says It's the final season and
then that was like four seasons ago
however I I think he just like he it's
what's more relatable than that like
working really hard on something and
being like okay never again and then a
month later being like well what if I
just did another season I it's like Tom
Brady he he they had a big premiere for
it and actually that guy so funny
remember that guy who worked at um I
think he went to Colgate the journalist
from e- news who like got fired for yeah
he got fired for like a shady reason now
he's like the face of variety feel like
nobody talks about that oh interesting
what's his name Ken Baker he went to
Colgate right yeah he
did um so not B uh who is this Ken Baker
yeah he went to colate he asked Larry
what is your favorite like what do you
think is the best episode of curb of all
time and Larry said and it couldn't be
more appropriate Palestinian chicken
yeah that is the best episode of TV like
ever it's it's just like a crazy episode
of TV it is but that's not my favorite
episode I couldn't tell you what my
favorite episode is but there's one
episode with the girl favorite episode
excuse me there's one episode oh my God
yeah there's one started talking at the
same time from 22 Jump Street she's also
in other stuff um Jillian what's her
last name j that's what I was that's
Ben's favorite episode where she wears a
crop top and Larry HS onto her
belly that's Ben's favorite episode
that's just like one that really sticks
out to me I remember after I saw it I
called you and I was like you have to
watch this episode it is Ben's favorite
episode well I'm so glad that you know
are crossed paths we would have ended up
at the same place anyway it's not about
the journey it's about the
destination yeah it's about the
destination and not interrupting people
as as frequently as you can I just think
it's so [__] important to remember
like we're literally on a delay here we
both started talking at the same time it
may have felt like I was interrupting
you but we started at the same time gas
okay like low key why am I lying like no
I interruped you yeah yeah yeah also I
actually wanted to come clean about a
lie I told earlier on the show I'm
buring yourself turty
I shared last maybe was it earlier in
this week or maybe last week like that I
hit a new milestone in my fitness
journey that I ran four minutes straight
like it was three I don't know why I
lied like I was just straight up making
stuff up it was three period yeah no
extra seconds like I'm sure maybe it was
like 32 or something but it wasn't four
minutes okay you're only lying to
yourself really I'm okay with that
yeah and maybe like if you told that lie
it it inspires you to actually get to
that 4 minute and it's motivational so
yesterday I was like okay if I just hit
the 4 minute then I it wouldn't have
been a li then you're not a liar I
literally couldn't I was dying cramping
you'll get there yeah so sorry about
that I'm coming
clean I think we should get into the
stories cuz we've got a lot to do today
and we're being like a little radical 25
minutes like what it's 25 minutes to at
23:30 not me making up numbers again
jeez Louise without further Ado here are
the fast five stories that you need to
know and the fast five stories that you
need to know are brought to you by
dossier after learning about the
incredibly High markup across the
designer perfume industry dossier began
their mission make luxury fragrances
accessible so at dosier each scent is
crafted of the best ingredients sourced
from grass France the perfume capital of
the world their expert perfumers are
among the industry's top noses each of
them having worked with the most
prestigious luxury brands that you see
on the market today fragrances cannot be
patented and the ingredients inside the
designer perfumes that you all love cost
about
$2 that's why dossier decided that it's
time to revolutionize the fragrance
industry and bring you the same designer
quality for a fraction of the cost all
the perfumes range from $29 to $49 and
today we have a discount code for all of
you so they have perfected a wide range
of designer fragrance Impressions yes
dupes inspired by some of the most
popular fragrances and a variety of
unique original perfumes for everyone to
find the personal scent I love that
somebody's tackling the fragrance
industry or as I like to call it the
water in a bottle it's literally insane
like you'll pay there are people who pay
$300 for a bottle of perfume and it's
literally water it's staggering what
perfume costs these
days it is staggering what perfume costs
these days and I just want to say I got
the dossier products and I got like a
sampler and it was so awesome because
they not only give you like I don't know
how many perfumes were in there maybe 10
but they it came with a one sheet of
like what each perfume what it's
inspired by the like designer it's a
doop and one I could smell it smells
exactly like something else and two like
now I'm a designer perfume girly for
fraction of the cost at dossier
indulging in luxury is personal pleasure
that everyone can enjoy so visit dossier
doco and use code toast at checkout for
10% off your next order that's d o SS I
r.co code toast for 10% off today's
episode is also brought to you by
neutral if you experien anything like
hair thinning shedding hair issues check
out neutri fall I feel like everybody
whenever anyone experiences like a hair
issue for the first time in their life
they all turn to nutrifol and everybody
I know has such good things to say about
it actually our sister Olivia just
started it so hair thinning is very
complicated it's much bigger than your
actual hair it usually doesn't even have
to do with your hair I know when I
experienced like really bad hair
shedding last year um it had to do
obviously with my drastic change in diet
and weight loss so there's always
something going on inside it can be
stress it can be hormones of course
postpartum um whatever the reason is
neutral is going to tackle that specific
reason with their hair Wellness quiz you
can get personalized hair health plans
today it's the number one dermatologist
recommended hair growth supplement with
over a million people seeing thicker
stronger faster growing hair and less
shedding the three-minute quiz
determines what the underlying root
causes are that are keeping you from
reaching your hair potential so by
analyzing your lifestyle biology hair
history as well environmental triggers
neutral creates a hair health plan that
is tailored to your hair needs so start
your hair growth Journey today by taking
neutri Fall's hair Wellness quiz get
your personalized hair health plan today
for a limited time nutriol is offering
our listeners $10 off your first month
subscription and free shipping at neutr
fall.com quiz when you enter promo code
the toast take the quiz and get started
on reaching your hair Wellness goals
with neutral today that's
nut.com quiz that promo code is the
toast neutr fall.com quiz promo code the
toast thank you la you are so
unbelievably welcome okay our first
story some Wendy Williams news as a new
trailer for her documentary has dropped
um Wendy is finally telling her side of
the story in a trailer for lifetimes
documentary called where is Wendy
Williams the iconic TV host openly
abuses alcohol and breaks down crying as
she details the financial strain she's
experienced from being placed under a
guardianship she says I have no money
the documentary features her son Kevin
Hunter Jr her sister Wanda and more
family members as they fight to help her
get well physically but also free her
from the financial prison in which she
finds herself her sister says we all
make choices in life we all go through
our challenges she still a person her
son also claims that her courta
appointed Guardian hasn't done a good
job of protecting Wendy and Wanda Echoes
that the system is broken Wanda says we
are her family and you tell me I'm not
capable of taking care of my sister what
would you do what should I
do I feel like everyone in the world has
been wondering like where in the world
is wend D Williams and now we know and
it's like worse than we could have
thought I really thought you was just
like taking time privately to deal with
her health issues also she was on TV
every day for many many years
maybe she just wants to like I don't
know be alone but the reality is much
worse and I'm glad she's making that
lifetime money because like she sold
this documentary this is a project this
is income yes but the guardianship is
kind of confusing it's like who is the
guardian and it seems like it's her
former or Current financial adviser at
like Wells Fargo and her money is like
there and Oh I thought she had no money
no I think she has no money because she
doesn't have access to it I was very
confused I was trying to like read more
about in like the Wells Fargo Guardian
like is like complains that she has to
have like armed security because of like
the
Wendy fans you know every like she's
kind of like the villain in this story
The Wendy fans like are extremely
zealous like it's a real Community I
just I don't understand what's happening
here and how like Wendy or her family
how they have a guardian placed on them
who is in charge of their money and she
doesn't have like access to it no I even
this lifetime money like does it go into
that pot is it more for the guardian I
also don't understand how um things went
so bad so quickly with Wendy Williams I
feel like she was on TV consistently for
so long and then she had some like
personal issues with her husband and
then her health and then boom she's
fired like I feel like it all happens so
quickly yeah also her physical health
isn't great in the documentary she's
like in a wheelchair and she's just
struggling so it's all very compounded
and I guess the documentary will get to
like the roots of each of these issues
but it's been a very hard few years for
her no and I highly recommend the
Lifetime movie that she produced about
her life Wendy Williams is a hustler I
feel like in like this day and age she's
like the butt of jokes but like people
don't realize like how major it was that
she got her own daytime show she like
started in radio she hustled so hard she
was like all about gossiping freely on
radio like not giving a [__] she started
in like the R&B space she made a lot of
enemies and it's she kind of has like a
amazing story now the Lifetime movie was
like hella dramatized and like lowkey
really stupid but I loved every minute
of it and I feel like we need a serious
Wendy biopic like she has a real story
for real like she's been through a lot
of stuff so I have a lot of sympathy and
I love Wendy like I really do yeah yeah
I and she's responsible for so many
iconic like viral moments
mhm I would ask people to respect my
privacy but I don't do it with those hot
topics that's the best video she's such
a queen like remember when she literally
fainted on air she's been through a lot
she's been through a lot so I don't even
know what like peace looks like for her
at this point you know is it a return to
TV cuz that's like what she does and who
she is but then on the other hand it's
like maybe she needs a break totally
unrelated but do we have it as a story
today that my Lord and Savior Darius
Rucker was arrested next up I'm
devastado about this next story hoodie
and the Blowfish frontman Darius Rucker
has been arrested for minor drug offense
in Tennessee Darius Rucker was arrested
on Thursday in Williamson County
Tennessee where he lives page 16 can
confirm the hoodie and the Blowfish
frontman was taken into custody and
booked in three count three misdemeanor
charges including two counts of simple
possession SLC casual exchange of a
controlled substance and one count of a
violation of the state's vehicle
registration law police accused Rucker
of driving with an expired registration
tag according to TMZ he was released is
that arrest worthy which I feel like
everybody's registration is literally
expired well in conjunction with these
other yeah I don't know I feel like
somebody has it out for Darius these
sounds like such minor offenses like I'm
really upset like I feel like Darius is
a good guy oh you think it's a
conspiracy against dararius I do like I
actually conspir it's a conspir Rucker
conspir Rucker well okay but I looked it
up casual exchange of a controlled
substance can mean like passing a joint
to someone totally that's what it sounds
like literally would you like to
casually exchange this controlled
substance with three Mis meaners two
counts of simple POS question simple
could be a joint in the pocket right no
and I feel like simp joint the pocket
for two counts literally and I feel like
simple means marijuana if it was
anything other than that whether like
prescription pills or cocaine like it
would have been not simple it would have
been
complicated oh no I feel like
prescription pills could be simple this
is just like a feel my feeling so I
could be totally wrong I feel like
prescription pills could be simple but
that was I prescription pills is like a
higher level and I would feel like
cocaine could be simple no oh there's
nothing simple about cocaine it's the
devil's drug I know but I just feel like
I feel like it could be simple
possession if it's just like a little
baggie no no I feel like they take
cocaine like really seriously and then
casual exchange of a control substance
like passing the baggie I just feel like
if I know anything about hoodie it's
that he's much more of a pop man like I
couldn't see hoodie doing blow like
railing lines I agree let's look at the
mug shot and it's unflattering it is not
a good mug shot I feel like again this
is a conspiracy against hoody like that
angle every that lighting it's so bad
like I feel like you can do a few like I
feel like they need to wipe the lens you
know on the back of the camera it's a
bad photo it's not a good look for hoody
the thing about like country fans is
they don't give a [__] like I don't
think this will affect hoody
whatsoever up until now I feel like he
does have a kind of Sterling reputation
but I did see a headline this morning
I'm going to pull it up like his
ex-girlfriend is out here like talking
about how this is karma for
hoodie H so like I don't like when
people you know when they kick someone
when they're down and I was of course
worried when I saw this headline that he
was
obviously arrested for a DUI cuz that to
me that's oh that's unforgivable it's
unforgivable Line crossing and I was
worried because I was getting you know
Sam Hunt flashbacks
however so his pot his ex is a comedian
and she posted on X saying yes I've
heard all I can say is karma heart ooh
what's her name and then she her name is
Kate Quigley and then she also posted a
selfie of her lounging in a blue bikini
with while sticking her tongue out and
she said mood when you hear your dag ex
got
arrested I st a Darius he's a National
Treasure I'm sorry I only want to be
with
you like I only want to be with Darius a
e
o
Darius Darius is one of those people
people like it would take a lot for me
to stop standing you know yeah and and
as we've like proven these are
misdemeanor simple charges could have
been
conspir it's
conspiratorial okay it's giving
conspiratorial energy yeah but I do
think just because he has such a
pristine reputation like it's not great
I think he'll survive it oh big time and
I I think people will forget soon like
remind set a calendar alert for like in
a year and see if we remember no and
like low key we shouldn't even made it a
story cuz we're contributing because
like literally no one's talking about
this cuz that's how much everyone just
loves hoodie like we're looking past it
yeah but it's a Friday and there like
wasn't much else so like don't get
arrested on a Thursday guys try for
Sunday oh my God it's so important that
if you're going to get arrested that it
be like towards the end of the week yeah
on the weekend buried love Thursday
stories were sparse today sorry d is but
at the end of the day it just depends on
the story like Erica Jaden
very smartly dropping her divorce news
during like one of the most heated
elections of our time we still cared
like I'm sorry it there was no undoing
that of course I actually I think she
intentionally dropped it on Election Day
to kind of bury it but yeah because
there was no other news because everyone
was talking about the election it was
kind of the only news if you didn't want
to talk about the election which is us
which is so true by the way like kind of
backfired
I can't believe there's like another
election seriously I hate election
season don't like I can't do you hate
all election Seasons like all every year
or just president just the president one
because I feel like there's not a lot of
like hype for like midterms and stuff
and like lowkey every time I vote in
like like a little like mayor Ro or
whatever I just feel like such a small
town girl like I really do love it and
it's like it's just it gives harmonious
energy it does people become the worst
versions of themselves everyone I'm
talking about during the election the
presidential election season like do not
talk to me like I I really can't yeah
but make sure you pack a snack and if
it's raining maybe an umbrella we
absolutely have to repost that clip
during election season the way
influencers acted last was it
presidential no that wasn't four years
ago was no that was President yeah I was
sitting in this chair four years ago
four years no it was a remote clip 2020
we were in that studio
law it wasn't a clip we didn't clip it
it's justun we did no it's a clip it's a
clip I I swear to God it's a clip moment
and it's remote and it must have just
been a regular election where people
influencers like were creating Graphics
like teaching people how to vote like
bring a snack grab an elderly neighbor
like we know yeah no if it's raining
like wear your rain boots and don't
forget your windshield wipers to turn
them on pack a
snack I can't yeah or like go to like
you know how to find your poing polling
place as if like it's not constantly
every time you open open up Facebook
Instagram it's like popup how toot it's
the same every year oh that too i' been
voting at the same like school for a
hundred years that too but I guess if
you're a new voter let's give them the
benefit of the fair fair if you're a new
voter like ash your parents no it's like
where do your parents vote right it's
really not hard um also if you're a new
voter lowkey like I assume you're maybe
in college like you can vote through
your college you can yeah actually
lowkey in when I was the first time I
ever voted I was in college and like
they did it for you in your dorm like it
was kind of like absentee energy cuz
you're obviously you weren't home and it
was also the year of Hurricane Sandy and
I got a letter in the mail like six
months after the election that my C my
ballot was never cast because of
Sandy interesting conspir I don't think
it was like an important election year I
don't remember what year it was Sandy
was
2012 I don't know all that to say my
vote didn't cast 2012 so oh no that
would have been a presidential election
law I want to say it was 201 13 actually
when I think about my college years when
I think about where I was during Sandy
it was
2012 you know what it was so crazy a
simple Google search oh I'm sorry I
wasn't thinking about hold on I think I
was thinking about hurricane
een no Sandy was like really major
Hurricane Sandy oh no 2012 I lived
through Hurricane Sandy like that's kind
of like a fun fact about me I was in New
York it was so crazy yeah I wasn't
really affected by it it was actually so
crazy how like in parts of the city like
people's cars were underwater like
downtown because the the city is kind of
on an incline and so 10 blocks up like
my lights flickered once that was the
most like craziest thing that happened
so I didn't really like live through
Sandy not to make everything about me
but she'll
try um so I'm sending well wishes to
Darius and just know like your OG fans
like your true fans we Riot for you and
we know this is not a reflection of who
you are and we know that there's a
conspiracy against you are you ready for
our next story a little more music news
because Ariana Grande is tearing up as
she previews vulnerable songs from her
upcoming album Eternal Sunshine so Ari
posted to Instagram a video of her with
like I guess some
um what's the thing label Big Wigs
members of her team yeah I was getting
like this is for the label of her
sampling her new album like talking
about the process of recording it and
when she started and what the
inspiration was but so she has a new
album coming out in March she started
recording right after the strike so this
is like you know SpongeBob era songs oh
wow SpongeBob era songs cuz SpongeBob
broke in the summer this I think she
started recording this in like September
when does the album come out
March I want to say like I do think
she's a Universal Music Group client I
do think releasing an album while umg
and Tik Tok like haven't worked things
out like will severely impact
streams like I it's it's actually like a
really big deal but they're not going to
work things out no I know and by the way
all my people have to still released
music I got notified yesterday like all
my Tik toks with the music is no longer
have been removed they're like silent
they're like you want to switch it up to
like
some public domain song I'm like no I'm
okay but they're not going to reach an
agreement so there's never a good time
to release the so it is what it is no
and Universal music group is quite
literally everyone except for me so
stream toast and 100% by Claudia asre
this could be a good opportunity for you
time to support Indie
artists straight up straight up well
this is you know exciting I feel like it
will be a good window into how she's
feeling about what's happened in her
life in the last 6 months and public
perception and all of that so by the way
is Ariana Grande the Justin Timberlake
of girls no
Okay Ariana Grande i' have to
think I have like yes and is giving I
owe an apology to nobody Cry Me a
River just
saying it's a thought starter I'm not
saying for sure it's a similar energy of
like I'm gonna do me right even if me is
bad but the things that Justin has to
answer for versus Ari are not really
comparable yeah no that's fair that's so
fair
yeah okay so would you say that like Ari
is a small scale JT or we're just hating
the comparison Al together the
comparison's not analogous for me I
understand
what what you're saying but it just
doesn't feel Apples to Apples fine Fair
I'll drop it I'll shut up I've her I
silenced her
finally okay do it what if I just go do
it our first walkoff can't be over this
can't be over this also I say that every
time I walk off our first walk off like
I've walked off like you've literally
never gotten
up that's that's cause for
leaving
bye-bye so are you guys ready for her
next story Let's Just Jump Right In oh
she's still wearing her headphones she
can hear me I wanted to catch her in the
middle she's back do you have anything
to
say do you have anything to say welcome
back
tury I'm sorry for disrespecting you
how by saying you didn't get up by
literally insinuating that I should like
kill
[Music]
myself um I'm sorry for
saying that you didn't get up you proved
me wrong that you got up so yeah cuz I
don't know about you but I did run for 4
minutes straight so I can't get up now
classic before we dive in I have
something to say okay today's episode is
brought to you by manscaped getting
ready for Valentine's Day and don't know
what to give the gift gift the GI don't
know what gift to give the man in your
life no worries manscaped is here to
save your love story with the all new
performance package 5.0 snag 20% off and
free shipping with code toast at
checkout it is The Ultimate Gift to
Elevate his grooming game and keep the
romance alive all year round so let's
zero in on the hero of Valentine's Day
the performance package 5.0 is basically
just a kit of grooming Essentials that
the man in your life needs the most
important thing I think in the kit is
the lawn mower 5.0 it's an electric
chimmer it features skin safe technology
it'll guard his sensitive areas from any
grooming mishaps also comes with an LED
spotlight which is super
bright the package also features the
weed whacker nose hair trimmer manscaped
liquid formulations two free goodies the
shed travel bag and the boxers Comfort
is King get 20% off free shipping code
toast manscape.com it's a gift for you
but it's a gift for your man also
getting your man something that gives
him a pouch men don't have pouches like
girls do and men need one good pouch and
I will say the one from the performance
package is fabulous Ben uses it all the
time and it is like his goto travel like
I have a th000 pouches but Ben has one
and that's really all he needs So 20%
off in free shipping with code toast
manscape.com that's 20 % off with free
shipping at
manscaped.com use code toast T here's to
keeping the romance alive one smooth
move at a time today's episode is also
brought to you by the new Lionsgate
movie scrambled that we've been talking
about all week that I'm so excited for
you guys to see because it comes out
February 2nd and today hey J what day is
it February 2nd groundouts day oh we
have to talk about that we have to talk
about that scrambled is in theaters now
so scrambled is a heartfelt yet
hilarious journey of self Discovery and
self-love it's written directed in
starring leam mckendrick who is quote
among Indie top Indie wire's top F top
female filmmakers to watch this year so
the plot of the movie is really just
like a relatable moment for I think a
lot of The Toasters quintessential
Eternal bridesmaid Nelly Robinson who's
of course played by leam mckendrick is
constantly finding herself between
weddings baby showers and bad dates when
she begins to feel like the clock is
ticking and is faced with Bleak romantic
prospects Nelly decides to freeze her
eggs scambled H setting her on an
empowering Journey To A Brave New World
where she ultimately discovers that the
one she's looking for you guessed it
might just be herself so film threat
says this is brilliant storytelling you
can learn more about the movie watch the
trailer at
lionsgate.com
slov scrambled the movie is out today is
it it is rated R it is in theaters now
so check it out I feel like this weekend
is raining in New York it's such a movie
weekend go to the theater get a snack a
soda treat self and goie scrambled just
a heartfelt a movie for the girls you
know yeah the trailer will make you cry
I love the actor who plays the brother
go check it out the movie is called
scrambled in theaters now it is rated R
get yourself a ticket and enjoy your
weekend is there anything better than
popcorn and soda no yes pretzels and
soda no french fries and soda go back
popcorn
and like chocolate thr in goldfish yeah
M&M's in a party mix yeah but
specifically popcorn and like really
salty buttery popcorn hot that you throw
the M&M's in the M&M's get really soft
yeah that's good I know what I'm going
to say like you're going to yuck my yums
so like can you just try to to put like
dried cranberries in there
raisinets oh dried cranberries literally
same thing I love raisinets I haven't
had them in Forever you walk off cuz
you're sick you walk off yucking yums
disgusting raisin nuts amongst other
things by the way bunch of crunch Loki
very good bunch of crunch is only sold
at movie theaters same with
dibs we have this conversation like once
a year I'm having Dej we need to talk
about groundhogs day because patani Phil
like knew that he was up on the chopping
block and homeboy did not see his shadow
spring is coming soon honestly like I
know it means nothing like it has no
bearing on the climate on Mother Nature
on the environment but when I saw that
news this morning like I perked the [__]
up and Peta wants to take that away from
us and that's why they're disgusting
yeah and P Satani like he doesn't give
us that early spring often often ever so
that when he does it means something it
means something but he also knew he
needed to give the people something so
that we continue to ride for him no and
it's nice like okay punk saton Phil
literally worked half a day and he
doesn't have to do it again for another
year like if that's not living in the
lap of luxury I don't know what is no
apparently his digs are Lux I am sure
what is I feel like he lives at like the
Gracie Mansion of Pennsylvania yeah and
they probably have like a whole little
caretaking team
yeah I'm happy for Phil Phil stays
winning know that I am speaking of do we
have a story about Demi levado today no
[__] but I you know what I'm going to
make that the fifth because I meant it's
funny it's so funny but our next story
is a lovely story about Jason Kelce who
is playing in the Pro Bowl this weekend
only so he can take his kids to Disney
relatable this was cute Jason Kelsey
says traveling for the Pro Bowl means a
Disney trip for his kids so he is in
Orlando to compete in the Pro Bowl this
weekend while there's football on the
horizon there's also family time for the
girl out of three who plans on taking
his daughters to Walt Disney World he
said I don't even know what you do in
the Pro Bowl anymore but it's down in
Orlando so I get to take my kids to Walt
Disney not off the Super Bowl Walt
Disney World but as long as Wyatt gets
to see Elsa I don't think it really
matters yeah yeah like it's that classic
thing when you win the Super Bowl what
are you going to do next I'm going to
Disney World I literally never
understood why the [__] they say that I
don't know now that I've been to Disney
I kind of understand no for sure and I
think they do go to Disney but like as a
team what's what's the
correlation I don't know can you look it
up I feel like as football girl he like
we need to know that yeah yeah why Super
Bowl and I think it's cute I think it's
cool actually that Jason Kelsey like
never plays in the Pro Bowl and he is
this year only because his kids want to
go to Orlando it's so cute and sweet and
like they don't know difference that
like you know Daddy lost so we're going
to Disney versus daddy won so we're
going to Disney right it's Disney but
what is the correlation and I feel like
is the Super Bowl even on ABC like ABC
is owned by Disney that I would
understand I feel like the Super Bowl is
like on
CBS it all started when Michael Eisner
or it's just a tradition which is nice
like there's no
monetary contract it all started when
Michael Eisner CEO of Disney and his
wife dined with a couple of aviators who
traveled the world nstop the wife asked
the pilots what they would do next and
they replied we're going to Disney World
okay what does that have to do with the
Super Bowl right how is that applicable
here like I know it's just a thing
people say that's where the idea of
promoting it for the Super Bowl came
from Walt Disney met with NFL organizers
and they reached an agreement for the
most valuable player to say the phrase
after the game oh wow this is like a
coordinated attack but is it like a
verbal
contract like now that's just a or do
they legally have to I imagine it's one
of those things like you always dream of
saying the first player to say he would
visit the famous Park and start in the
company's commercials was Phil Sims who
won in 1987 with the Giants according to
reports the MVP earns between $3 and
$50,000 just for saying the iconic
phrase so I guess if you win and you say
it you get paid and if you don't you
don't I feel like they always say it
it's one of those things like if you
want to be a football star it's like
your biggest dream is to say it but $30
to $50,000 when's that article from cuz
I feel like with inflation like it
should be 250
2023 and I by the way I did read I I
wanted to talk to you about this that a
lot of um the players playing in the
Super Bowl this weekend have like
incentive based bonuses in their
contract if they a make it to the Super
Bowl if they win the Super Bowl so I
think I read Patrick Mahomes will make
like another million dollars just for
getting to the Super Bowl pro py has a
uh it's not a lot of money but he'll
make like a nice little bonus like six
figures low six figures so there are
like you know merit-based bonuses packed
into these NFL
salaries that I'm glad to hear though I
do think like Brock should kind of make
up the difference of the fact that he's
not making Super Bowl money yeah no it
for
sure but anyways I hope that the Kelsey
family has a blast this weekend me too
at Walt Disney I'm looking at a picture
of them from the last time they went to
Disney and it looks like no I was going
to say it looks like they have that
double stroller that Olivia has that I
hate but this one looks a little
different they would never we were
clowning on Olivia's stroller in the the
patreon episode like you guys are so
mean no like me and shabir she needs a
new double stroller why it like doesn't
the wheels don't work it's literally
about to the kids are like sardines it's
just a piece of crap by the way like get
her one like stop complaining obviously
it bothers you more than it bothers her
that's true so go get her
one that's true put my money where is
yeah no there's one I have she the one
pushing it there's one I have in mind
for her she's literally the one pushing
it and she doesn't appear to be
complaining I know but I just feel like
she's she's become stubborn about it
she's like trying to prove something to
me that like the stroller works and
prove to her husband by the way that's
so something Olivia would doic suffer in
silence just for the point yeah totally
now are you ready for our fifth and
final story I am Demi levado performs
her song Heart Attack for heart attack
survivors Demi levado performed her song
Heart Attack for a room full of heart
attack survivors and some audience
members were not
impressed Demi was the head liner at the
American Heart association's Go Red For
Women red dress collection concert
that's a mouthful on Wednesday in New
York City where she sang some of her
biggest hits including sorry not sorry
cool for the summer confident skyscraper
heart attack according to her according
to an eyewitness it was her choice of
the song Heart Attack that raised a few
eyebrows they said quote she was belting
heart attack in front of the class of
2024 who were all survivors of heart
attacks there was a video package played
before the fashion show and concert
where the women all shared their brushes
with death via heart attack how they
were all saved during a heart attack one
has a pacemaker for the rest of her life
Demi was smiling the entire
perform oh my God Demi was smiling the
entire performance and it was really
toned deaf I one eyewitness I wasn't
there so I can't really like really read
the room of the tone like I don't know
how it went down but like this might be
the most iconic thing Demi lado has ever
done it's Peak comedy it's so funny and
like lowkey you survived a heart attack
like lighten up like this is funny it is
that's funny funny and I also feel like
if I were Demi Lovato maybe oh I'm
performing for the Heart Association of
course perfect I have a song called
right just about this thing and it's
like one of my most popular
songs yeah I feel like read the lyrics
read the lyrics let me I was literally
about to pull them M I feel like maybe
she was even asked to perform because
she has a song about the subject matter
yeah of course put in my defenses up cuz
I don't want to fall in love just speak
it if I ever did that it's going to be
hard but I'll try I think I'd have a
heart attack okay yeah I guess if she
fell in love she would have a heart
attack is kind of the moral of the story
I guess the hard part of the song is
right after this course she probably
says the phrase heart attack like 10
times heart attack like she keeps saying
it the the point the last five lines if
I ever did that I think I'd have a heart
attack I think I'd have a heart attack
heart attack I think I'd have a heart
attack tack I think I'd have a heart
attack
oh oh I think I
have oh I think I'd have a heart attack
wait I'm just want to say one two three
4 5 6
78 as she ends the song she says I think
I'd have a heart attack eight
times and perhaps that's where some of
the outrage has stemmed from and and
that I definitely do understand
now I feel like all heart attack
survivors are different so I think maybe
like some of them like thought this was
funny and some of them thought this was
insensitive cuz like Loki I don't know
how I would act if I had a heart attack
but I think it would be I would find it
funny
yeah yeah I think that it would kind of
be Rudder for her to not sing heart
attack it would have been like oh the
elephant in the room she has guys can't
handle the song right I think she was
giving them a lot of credit yeah too
much credit clearly no they're like a
strong group of survivors I think she
thought that they like they've been
through worse yeah I also love how the
article is like an eyewitness as if this
was like a
catastrophy it was I'm obsessed I ground
there are certain moments in history
that I like would do anything to have
witnessed firsthand and like I don't
even think a video of this would like I
needed to feel the energy in this room
but to me this is 10 points in
demetrius's column and don't come for me
my father died of a heart attack you can
eat my ass oh yeah so we could say I
feel like we needed to clarify that that
like oh yeah like we have been touched
our opinions like matter here and I the
American Heart Association the American
Heart Association like failed Our Father
Like
We right can say we can say this is
funny this is hysterical and I do feel
like right now they'll probably try and
like distance themselves from it but I
feel like someone on the committee was
like we should have Demi performed she
has a song about this very
thing
it's like breathtakingly synergetic I
love every minute of it yeah the end oh
and it's a Bop too right pop that [__]
you survived a heart attack it's a great
song and look at Demi donating her time
to a cause that might have like an
important I'm sure she was paid
handsomely really I feel like things you
do for free no no these associations
have so much money I know but shouldn't
that money go to like I don't know
finding a cure for heart attacks or
whatever no it's like they go to getting
Demi levado so that more people buy
tickets so that they can raise more
money yeah but like imagine if Demi just
donated her
time I don't think that's how it works I
don't know if I don't know I don't know
either but also this is also great PR
for the American Heart Association
because I didn't know that they had a a
g Suare this mon no I know that they
have their walk they love love their
walk Walking is good for the heart
exactly so is
laughing keep keep singing Jackie
walking is good for the toast and so is
laughing so sit down and listen to the
toast so is singing and dancing to a
great song such as heart
attack such
as so those are the Fast Five the good
news is that while the stories may be
over the show is not because we have our
new segment that we have not forgotten
today Friday where we kind of wrap up
the week by bestowing two prestigious
honors upon four different people Jack
and I both are going to nominate someone
who acted in in a wey like manner this
week and we are going to give them the
award of the weenie of the week and
we're going to give an award to the
Queenie of the week someone who we
thought showed
great
fortitude Against All
Odds so I think let's start with
Queenie I'm feeling motivated to
nominate Demi
Lovato oh I love for Queenie for Queenie
for her brilliant choice of song No this
kind of was like how a queen would
act I love that I completely agree and
I'm feeling motivated to nominate the
weenies as the eyewitnesses in
attendance who couldn't dance along I
love that I'm feeling motivated for that
it's giving like weenie energy like come
on I completely agree it's it's actually
giving the definition of like weenie
that's why we started this yeah because
I was going to do a different weenie but
like weenie is not meant to be you know
I'm a serious so serious it's just like
weeny you did something a little weenie
and I don't want like other weenies to
like then feel like oh my God I was in a
category with this person like it's so
true it's not a title I feel like laa
Ken it's not something you should wear
forever it's just for the week it's a
moment in time yeah and next week like
you could even be weenie one week and
Queenie the next for sure my Queenie
this week is Margo Robbie like I think
the way she responded to the snub like
she could have really dug in her heels
and been such a victim and I actually
would have put her in weenie but the
fact that she was like listen other
women were nominated it's all good
everyone seriously calm down love and
respect love and respect to that
statement why aren't you saying
anything you just like love dipping into
the Barbie I do I love starting stuff
you love starting stuff and that like
here you are being one of those people
that's like Barbie Margo Robbie's a
queen for the way she handled oh my God
you think I'm acting like a Barbie Stan
kind of you're like kind of obsessed no
I mean Jackie like think about how
far-reaching the Oscar snub story went
like Hillary Clinton's statement and
Margaret Robbie could have been like
such a [__] loser about it and she
wasn't yeah sorry she deserves credit
yeah but she wouldn't have been even if
you know she's has daggers at the hfpa
up on her wall like she knows that
that's that's not the way that you act
right so that's Queen Behavior okay
agreed now my we is someone I really
wish I did last week and I thought about
this person all week okay it's Jessica
Beal for weenie for weenie that eating
in the shower thing like the more I
think about it like it's [__] it's
literally the definition of weenie it's
so
losery I feel like honestly like it
requires no further explanation no it
does and I can't even look at a yogurt
without I really I can't think look at
at Clementine I can't look at the shower
yeah without think shall I have a
snack yeah no no there will be no
further explanation like Jessica be is
my weenie of the week I thought about it
all week and I was so mad at myself for
not choosing her last week when we
talked about it in the episode on Friday
but it needed to marinate
yeah so with that we will bid you a du I
hope everyone has a great weekend I hope
you have a great weekend tury I will
good you should cuz it's the one you got
it's your weekend thank you guys so much
for listening to the toast ja and I are
both like coughing sneezing sniffling
I'm not even doing the wrap up goodbye
love you
bye